Marvel fans, I am here with
Jamie Foxx who plays Electro.
What is it like returning
to this character
after all this time?
It's been amazing, man.
Like to be able to
reboot the character.
New look, new vibe.
And my kids here with
me representing Electro.
They got the shoes.
Representing Electro,
they got the shoes.
So we just been, just been
happy to be on this ride
and can't wait for the
world to see the movie.
What's different
about Electro this time?
Well, the way he
looks right off the bat.
It's a different look.
He's super fly, potent, kind
of got a flyness to him.
And so everybody online has
been really reacting well to it,
so just can't wait for
people to check it out.
I heard you brought
your own flavor to it.
Yeah.
Yeah, you know, you got to
bring your flavor to it.
So you know, the fact that
they were allowing, you know,
accommodating with that makes
the whole movie feel better.
Yeah.
Well I'm excited to see it.
What's the best part about
playing a super villain?
Oh, it's always
good to be a bad guy.
It's good being bad,
you know what I mean?
So it's like you're
doing Electro,
there's so many layers when
you're a super villain.
You know what I mean?
So I can't wait for
you to check that out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]